as we all know crop occurs general
mission in life is to collect the
scarlet eyes of his clan however on this
quest he also developed an additional
hobby of collecting all things scarlet
scarlet drapes
Scotty sets Scott which comics but most
importantly of all the scarlet subscribe
button for the new world review the
pressing of which will result in regular
Hunt under content uploaded straight
into your YouTube feed hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today
it's hunter hunter once again as it
often is and I would like to go over
five things that we simply need to see
on the Dark Continent and here we queue
all of the comments about how law will
never get their lazy Takashi rah-rah-rah
and look we don't like to think that way
on this channel because there is a whole
ton to potentially get excited about in
regards to this dark continent and a
surprising amount for those threads have
been laid out right in front of our eyes
which is why it kind of irks me when
people say we know nothing about the
Dark Continent because that simply isn't
true we know an absolute ton about it so
much so that it filled a 12-minute video
on this channel linked in the
description below if you are interested
but in addition to that we also have a
pretty decent idea of what to expect
upon arriving there so with that in mind
let's begin welcome to the top 5 things
we need to see on the Dark Continent
number 5 a new calamity or threat
depending on what translation you
subscribe to but the existence of the
calamities are arguably what makes the
prospect of the Dark Continent so
intriguing because it isn't just an
incomprehensibly big landmass it also
plays host to an entire ecosystem of
beings each of whom could potentially
wipe out humanity with very minimal
effort and just a list a simple example
we have nanika a dark continent native
who is capable of well essentially
anything at this stage Anika is more or
less the closest thing that hunter
Hunter has to a god-like being and their
power could well and truly be infinite
just with the one little restriction of
having it be the wish of someone else
but we have less godlike creatures as
well such as hell Belle who appears to
be something of a glorified snake but
who is said to infect its prey with
homicidal desire meaning that a couple
of bites goodly to mass murder and then
if you have an entire congress of snakes
and that is humanity done and dusted
wrapped up in a nice little package this
is what the Dark Continent represents
and every known expedition there has
resulted in the encounter of one of
these apocalyptic beings and so when we
do eventually arrive on the Dark
Continent I would expect nothing less
than to have a new one pop up and be the
focus of this particular voyage but not
only that in order to be
keeping with Takashi's brilliant
escalation narrative I would expect this
new calamity to be significantly more
terrifying than any of the ones we've
previously encountered at the same time
though I don't think it's completely out
of the realm to possibly suggest that
whatever primary force we're dealing
with might come to be somewhat humanized
by the end of the arc you know like a
marijuana tuile situation where the
table slip the calamity turns out to be
the good guy and the true evil is
someone like Conan beyond natural who
comes bearing the worst that humanity
has to offer and perhaps for the first
time that were aware our humanity won't
be constrained for the calamity upon
returning into Lake Mobius or maybe the
opposite will happen and they will
willingly take the calamity back for
whatever reason either way the true
drama of the Dark Continent can only be
catalyzed by a profound threat that will
certainly present itself as one of if
not the biggest challenge that we have
ever seen in the series number four the
gatekeeper and the guide here is an
existence that I think most casual hunt
hunt fans seem to kind of skim over and
forget but the thing is without the
gatekeeper and the guide it would seem
that it is entirely impossible to reach
the Dark Continent in the first place
and essentially the gatekeeper despite
having a very singular sounding
translation is actually a race of
magical beasts who hold the only known
passage to the Dark Continent so each
and every time humanity has ventured
there they have assumedly gone through
this magical beast middleman and I guess
what I'm most excited about in regards
to this is obviously finally learning
what kind of creatures the gatekeepers
are but also delving more into magical
beasts in general because in the series
as we know it they are a criminally
under explored aspect of hunter hunter I
mean off the top of my head I can
probably name one type of magical beasts
which of the Kirikou shapeshifters and
yeah the chimera ants went on to be
classified as magical beasts which does
even prompt the idea that perhaps all
magical beasts were originally from the
Dark Continent and that there is
actually this race of supremely
intelligent magical beasts that hold far
more control over the world then even
humanity does but that aside there is
also the intrigue of the guide who is
supposedly a being summoned by the
gatekeeper and they are the ones
responsible for chaperoning beings to
the Dark Continent
the guide is also the one responsible
for forcing humanity to bring calamities
back to the human realm after
unsuccessful trips so this being is
obviously incredibly powerful and may
even be one of the most fantastic uses
of nen that we will ever get to see
given that the guide may be a conjured
presence because nothing in this world
exists by a magic alone or even magical
beasts it's usually on end so when we
talk about summoning
by talking about either conjuration or
specialization in regards to the guide
but of all the things we need to see on
the Dark Continent the gatekeeper and
the guide all ones that we would
encounter incredibly early on in the arc
and I very much look forward to that
whenever that time maybe number three
chimera ants wait what why chimera ants
we've already seen these guys at great
length I mean not only that but they
take up almost an entire third of the
series so why do we need to see them
again and the answer is because it would
be fun and I don't mean that we bring
them back too heavily focus upon them
and we certainly don't have them in the
incarnation that they represented in
their art but we do know that their
specific giant species did originate
from the Dark Continent and the Queen
ended up in the human realm through very
unknown means however she is but one
queen of one colony and ants being ants
there are very likely many many many
colonies of ants out there in existence
I think it would be really cool to
reference that when we do visit the Dark
Continent so it could just be an initial
encounter whereby a group of hunters are
assaulted by a squad of ants but because
they've already dealt with that threat
before in the human world
they'll just be quickly dispatched and
no mera web style situation will have
time to occur although I do think it
would be very interesting to see what
the base form of a chimera ant King and
their world guard would be because the
only thing we got to see in the series
was the base form of the Queen and yeah
it certainly would not be as interesting
as the ones we came to know in the
series due to the lack of humans to
consume as well as not having access to
nen but a really fun contrast
nonetheless and a nice piece of
connective tissue to the rest of the
series really emphasizing just how much
this Dark Continent has gone on to
influence this world and not only that
but it might even be an appropriate plot
point to focus on because remember that
a certain para Stan Hill is currently in
command of an army of thousands of
chimera and human hybrids all of whom an
end users which remains one of the more
terrifying thoughts in hunt hunter but
if any or all of them were brought to
the Dark Continent then there might be a
couple of central figures who get to
meet their ancestors and even grapple
with the idea of where they came from
and I don't know this is probably all
just weird and wishful thinking for me
but once again I'm not saying they
should be a major focus because we've
already gone down that route in the
series in fact they almost certainly
should not be a major focus but some
chimera ants making an appearance in a
chapter or two well that would just be a
nice nod to the journey that we've had
so far
number two beyond natural versus
everyone alright now here is something
that I am perpetually excited about
because from everything we've been given
thus far it heavily implies the beyond
does not only
an exceptional powerhouse of his own but
that he also has no allegiance to well
anybody beyond is the kind of man who is
gunning for the Dark Continent for his
own selfish and seemingly sinister and
mysterious purposes and as such in order
to achieve that he spent half a century
just preparing for this voyage to take
place and this time around he is not
going to let anyone or anything stand in
his way
and I highly doubt that his interest
coincide with anybody else setting foot
on the landmass I mean we know for a
fact that the zodiacs being set up to
confront him thanks to Isaac metros
challenge and while beyond is sitting
quietly in custody currently that is
going to change rapidly when he gets his
first whiff of the continent perhaps
resulting in a conflict where he takes
on and even defeats multiple members of
the zodiacs but beyond is a character
who has the potential to make many many
more enemies and I don't think it's
unreasonable at all to foresee a clash
between Beyond and Jing or perhaps even
Paris 10 or even the entirety of his own
expedition team because despite the fact
that beyond is the one organizing them
he has been shown to be exceptionally
dishonest with them regarding the danger
of the continent and is clearly using
them to achieve a very specific goal and
as for anyone else who sets foot there
well they're no friend of beyond either
whether that's the Phantom troupe who
are always against everyone else or even
some of the remnants of the cocking
Empire who by this point would be well
aware that beyond went along with the
plan to deceive them so in the end this
man has very few and arguably no allies
and you know what he doesn't really view
that as a problem and that is both
endlessly exciting as well as sends a
great chill down my spine just thinking
about how the power of a network could
be applied to a truly malevolent purpose
and yet my most anticipated thing that
we need to see on the Dark Continent is
still to come number one
dawn freaks now this figure is quite
possibly the most intriguing presence in
the entire series and his existence was
only revealed I guess quite recently in
the grand scheme of things but this dawn
freaks presents us with the one being
the we know of who has managed more or
less effectively conquer the Dark
Continent conch is probably not the
right word but I guess cohabitate with
the Dark Continent a location that made
Isaac natura himself sweat and claim
that the only victory to be had there
was survival itself and it's safe to say
that Don has achieved that victory
although evidently Don has a very
different philosophy to network and over
300 years ago he made the voyage out
there and began travelling the shoreline
of Lake Mobius loking his experience in
a book known as
journey to the new world which is
supposedly split up into the east and
west editions and we have seen one of
these being the east edition which logs
a wealth of information concerning one
side of the shoreline but the West still
has yet to be found and just why is that
well mr. jenks ryx believes that's
because it has yet to be completed and
the dawn is still traveling the dark
continent composing his journal to this
very day making him well over 300 years
old which is amazing to think about but
also very possible because we are well
aware of the existence of at least one
substance on the dark continent known as
nitro rice which can extend your life
possibly into eternity and I'm sure that
there is an incredible wealth of other
benefits out there as well but the
incredible thing is thinking about what
kind of man dawn must be to be able to
constantly survive being surrounded by
beings that can wipe out the entirety of
humanity with great ease and dawn is not
the entirety of humanity he is one man
and at the very least for one whole half
of the lake maybe a shoreline he was
able to integrate himself into a very
brutal ecosystem of this area and that
is an achievement that I don't think any
other character in the series could hope
to live up to
I mean maybe marijuana but that dude is
practically a god and the ants were from
the continent to begin with so but that
is why Don is a man who we must see on
the Dark Continent or at the very least
the legacy that he is left behind
perhaps Jing won't even find on but he
will stumble upon the west edition of
his journal in any case we simply need
more information about this figure who
is intrinsically linked to the dark
continent as well as the freaks family
and thus the very fabric of Hunter
hunter as we know it but what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
on the Dark Continent in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hunt on
content and please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunt unto glory delivered straight into
your YouTube feed but for now this has
been the new world view and I'll see you
next time